وهذه المدن
الجميله
بحاجه لمن يحبها لكي تصبح جميله يعني كل
امكنه تحتاج لمن يحبها لتصبح اكثر جمالا
ليس هذه ميزه مغربيه يعني انا نتيجه
تجوالي في بعض المدن بحس في حب من اهل
البلاد ومن القيمين على هذه البلاد في
جعله جميل وانيقه ومرحب
ومطمئنه لزائرها ولاهلها المدن في المغرب
بسرعه عامه هي الذخيره الاساسيه
للحضاره المغربيه
وللاستقرار المغربي تعرف نحن من الممكن ان
تزور عددا كبيرا من المدن في المغرب وتدرك
من اول وهله
انها لا تختلف كثيرا عن العواصم او عن
العاصمه لان لها نفس المؤهلات لها نفس
بنايه التحتيه لها نفس متوفر فيها نفس
الخدمات
وهذا الامر يذكرني بجولات كنت قمت بها في
بعض بلدان المشرق العربي
وكانت الملاحظه الاساسيه التي اخرج بها هو
ان البلاد كبيره لكن فيها مدينه واحده
كبيره او مدينتين كبيرتين يعني والباقي
عباره عن قرى متمدنه بينما المغرب فيها
اولا عواصم امبراطوريه لان الملكيه وراءها
قرون
والامبراطوريه المغربيه كانت ممتده عبر
مساحات جغرافيه شاسعه وفي كل مره كانت بعض
المدن
تكون هي العاصمه فاس كانت عاصمه مراكش
كانت عاصمه مكناس كانت عاصمه قصدي انه
المغرب شمالا وجنوبا يتوفر على بؤر حضريه
قويه مطمئنه وفيها تنتج كثير من الاشياء
التي تساهم في تشكيل الهويه المغربيه وفي
هذه المدن انصهرت التيارات الاندلسيه
والتيارات الامازيغيه وتيارات اخرى
المدن عباره عن عن مظاهر حقيقيه لادماج
المكونات المختلفه للهويه المغربيه التي
تصنع هذا الجمال